service und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen video heute sitzen wir wieder in
unserem garten denn heute dreht sich
alles um pokémon und zwar haben wir hier
meine bescheidene sehr bescheidene
pokémon sammlung die geben wir kurz
unsere kamerafrau und die kamerafrau
gerne ja genau was ich sagen wollte hier
ist meine bescheidene pokémon sammlung
die geben jetzt an unsere kamera und die
wird jetzt zufällig pokémon aus meiner
pokemon um auswählen und deren geräusche
abspielen darum dreht sich das ganze
video denn ich trete gegen markt an und
wir versuchen geräusche von pokémon
foggo zu erwarten ich glaube das ganze
ist gar nicht so leicht
also ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht
also wir sind ja mit pokémon aufgewacht
und wir kennen eigentlich jedes programm
beim namen oder zumindest aus den
klassischen version version version
genau aber gehör wird richtig schwierig
dazu muss ich noch sagen früher als sich
pokémon roth gespielt habe da konnte ich
tatsächlich alle pokémon am geräusch
erkennen alle 101 50 aus der roten und
das sind 1 nicht aus pokémon go aber das
sind acht jahre her oder sowas von
elektrisch damit habe ich zu meiner oma
gesagt dass ich damit zu wetten dass
geben möchte
legen wir los leute wir machen das ganze
mit einer 5 hat ich werde die pokémon in
den ersten zehn sekunden nach dem
geräusch verpixelt anzeigen dass ihr
selbst mit raten könnt und erst dann den
blur aussehen soll ich etwas pokemon
firefox
dabei mache habe ich gleich gefangen
aber es ist keiner carlina
ja die ganze ereignis pokémon ich habe
sie erkannt dass ich selbst damit
gefangen aber ein einziges mal gesehen
gefangen sie als sein
das ist ein supertag sind es 21 para
elektro elektro ball nicht kein
elektronischen tipp geben genau sein typ
das ganze war geist gibt es gibt ja nie
gehört
es ist das noch
vorhin klingt zwar alles nach elektro
pokémon es ist kein elektro fahrrad ist
das auch nicht was ist und ich würde ich
sagen okay ist es ein käfer pinsel habe
ich nicht gefangen ist und wissen immer
erwischt erwünscht weil es noch die
halbinsel sport bei uns in der stadt
findet spot jedes mal wenn wir da waren
ist es mir entwischte erschien biber
haben fieber
okay okay da und die klassiker paris
nach gräfrath nebula okay da hat mir die
typen wie jesus nicht feuer ist nicht
wasser ist nicht elektrifiziert gekommen
ist es nicht psycho es ist nicht boden
gestein okay ist es ist nicht eins ist
es als wir auf alle drei als käfer
pflanze haben wir noch irgendwelche
nicht gesagt kampf sagte typ a330 bei
wollte heute hab ich gern electric es
ist auch schwere die kinder leni
vergleich aber das ist irgendwie nie
kaputt sagte wancata dollar und klingt
ja so schockiert kann man müsste wir
sind total fischer land alle unser leben
stargäste entscheidung mit leichtem
sport könnte sein wenn ich jetzt den
wundert mich gemacht denn er muss dafür
ja was wir da muss mir übrigens ein
account schenken erinnert euch als
vorhergesagt dass max in der kirche
erinnerte was ich bereit das ist ganz
einfach
das könnte vielleicht stern boksics
durch zu 50 stück an der natürlich
weiter
lena ich hier im moment verliert und
einfach keine ausrede haben weißt du
schon mal die kommentare werden so
scheiße ich weiß nicht was du drauf hat
und innerhalb von 0,3 sekunden statt 06
sekunden kann ich weiß nicht wie viele
das so sehr suchten dass sie die töne
raten können aber es ist auf jeden fall
sehr interessant gewesen also ich hätte
das wäre echt einfacher rudi pokemon
sind relativ einfach samen vom aussehen
her aber die sounds hat gar nicht so
unterschiedlich wie seit so traumatisch
ist mega mega klar zu erkennen und
karasek auf mit seinem picacho arbeit
habe sich einfach alles
mit diesem wunderschönen pokémon
go-go-girls schreibt meine kommentare
wie viele hier erkannt hat und innerhalb
kurzer zeit und hat sich die darauf
ausruhen sondern ganz cool von euch das
3 und last auf jeden fall wieder in
einer 33 33 33